PRIYANKA VERGADIA: If you are
migrating to Google Cloud,
you are probably wondering how
your team's responsibilities
might change.
How do you ensure
that users remain
in continuous compliance, and
how do you manage and analyze
cost?
Well, keep watching as we
answer some of these questions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to Cloud migration 101,
where we share migration tips
and tricks.
In the last two
episodes, we learned
about resource hierarchies,
access control,
permissions using IAM, security,
networking, and monitoring
within Google Cloud.
Today, let's address
some of the questions
that impact your broader
business objectives.
For this, let's get Travis back.
TRAVIS WEBB: Hi, I'm Travis.
Today, we are going to focus
on three main questions
that business stakeholders
worry about during a migration.
As you migrate to Cloud, how
will your IT responsibilities
and business processes change?
How can you support and meet
your regulatory compliance
requirements?
And how will you assess and
analyze costs and billing?
Let's get started with
the most common scenario.
You have owned and operated
your data center for years.
How will your ownership,
access, and responsibility
change as you migrate
to Google Cloud?
During and after your migration,
the shared responsibilities
between you and Google Cloud
may be different than those
you were used to.
The processes to provision,
configure, and consume
resources might also differ.
We have added a link
in the description
for the terms of service and
the Google security model that
will provide you an overview
of the contractual relationship
between your
organization and Google.
You're probably wondering
how can you support or meet
your regulatory
compliance needs--
for example, HIPAA or GDPR--
during and after your
migration to Google Cloud.
We provide a robust
compliance resource center
that can provide information
about industry, region,
and sector-specific regulations,
like PCI, GDPR, HIPAA,
FedRAMP, and many more.
If geography and data residency
are critical factors for you,
Google offers resource
location constraints
to ensure workload compliance
with data residency
requirements and direct
regionality controls
for many of our services.
Now, as you move
to Google Cloud,
how can you make sure that
your users support and meet
your compliance needs?
Developing a
governance strategy is
important to create
alignment among stakeholders
in business leadership.
When planning your
migration, you
want to establish
standards around things
like naming conventions,
labeling strategies, access
and security controls,
and cost controls.
Speaking of cost, Cloud Billing
helps you control, assess,
and analyze cost.
It allows you to
attribute spending
on a particular project or
workload to the correct cost
center.
You can also set up alerts
for your spending budget.
For example, you could
use Cloud Functions
to enforce and monitor a
compliance S code solution
to verify names and labels
on provisioned resources,
and inspect your own IAM
policies and resource
hierarchy to ensure the
standards are being followed.
With this solution, you gain
full auditing capabilities
as a byproduct of every
service and action.
The last question I would like
you to answer for yourself
and your organization is,
what type of support and help
you need in order to
take on the migration?
The answer could be, you
will do it all yourself
with the help of training
and certifications,
or you would do it
partially with a partner,
or completely handed
off to a partner.
You have options
depending on where
you are in your Cloud journey.
Talk to your Google
team for best guidance.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: All
right, Travis, I got this.
TRAVIS WEBB: All
right, back to you.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
That was amazing.
We learned about
governance, billing,
and some important
enterprise considerations
like shared responsibility
models and data residency.
For more details, check out
the entire guide linked below.
And stay tuned for the next
episode, where we will take
this migration journey forward.
In the meantime, give us a like,
subscribe, and comment below
to let us know what
else you would like
to learn about Cloud migration.
[MUSIC PLAYING]